and a walk welcome to video playing mr.
McKee I'm Australian don't provoke
Bishop g2 ok this is also quite
interesting him this position there are
some Quincy to ideas yeah I kind of I
wonder seem soon Quincy to my prince to
96 is playable anyway let's do it taking
too long for this I'm looking at this
Bishop there so he has to react in some
way you cannot just develop the bishop
or something but he can go both Bishop
d7 and 10 96 96 let's 69 a4 could be
tactically interesting Queen to see 795
it doesn't it doesn't get to all that
much but maybe it's interesting and
let's try that not completely sure if
this is actually doing much at the end
so we should be five horse my IDM I have
shipped his home that's kind of strange
now that was a bad idea actually it was
a bad idea 94 pretty bad move okay now
that was a bad opening claim
Oh Bishop a sick so I'm really playing
badly this game oh now I have 95 at
least but now this is ok actually but I
didn't I didn't really see it beforehand
it doesn't have a great movie i believe
there should be 50 Bishop c4 gets kicked
with B 3 a 4 respectively Bishop c4 b3
Bishop c5 also doesn't feel all that
grade yes it looks nice on the bishop
but i also have a pretty good diagonal
here with bishop to be true so let's put
this on that diagonal
I cannot cancel he quite obviously but
i'm not sure if I need to so yeah I
always have route 83 if I absolutely
have to land additional cover down yeah
g45 is interesting let's do it getting
more space ok so what to see when he
wants to go look to be eight an
interesting thing is that
I cannot easily play okay through this
Bishop c4 it's an idea that i did not
see beforehand
Bishop c4 it's interested in interesting
technical idea I had its it's very very
problematic actually yeah I don't know I
have to do it and now Bishop a1s Bishop
c4 no it is actually not threatening as
my rookie is protected okay so
it's actually not that much of a problem
if I lose that poem because i get i
trade all the trade or negative pieces
that he has this is not i think such a
big issue
Bishop d7 for instance is quite a bit of
a problem that night is just so bad i'm
not sure if he actually should have
taken this material
time warning so if to watch out here of
course from the time situation
check
hmm Moxie to check is night is six stuff
here check check it's funnier the King
position but it's rather active still
not entirely sure about this I can
invade you with the rook this is a good
position even
I move the bishop and threatening look
c8 mate this is not not easy the aide is
also covered all right it's a good two
hands actually hmm ok I should have gone
there then checkmate that's a nice mate
yeah there was a wild game in a strange
game and probably not a good game I made
a really bad opening play him and I I
now remember what I did wrong what I
have to do is I have to play this this
and now Quincy to that was actually this
is what I have um in nine opening files
for my video series am the difference
difference is that here without the sea
pawn trade there is no knight c6 so now
I'm threatening to take here and take
the 54 it's for example this and this
would blend at the house so black
usually does this and it goes from here
here white has a couple of interesting
options for example you can play a three
to two play be four next leading to
interesting play on the queenside and
then that's what I should have done and
this isn't all that great iam now after
96 yes still I should avoid 94 we can
actually take here whoa was it even
bigger missing a thought wow the other
would have one instantly yeah okay the
move was bad I mean even this is just
not great yeah this is I'm not sure what
I think this actually should be quite
good for white but maybe I'm wrong
no the engine things are wrong okay I
can I can do this and be somewhat okay
okay then i miss evaluated this year
totally i was thinking that that
diagonal and gives me very good on play
for that problem with the beep on but it
doesn't seem to materialize I computer
is really booming oil this is a brutal
move pawn takes Knight the five is
terrible and this is also crashing
through for black already so I was
really lucky him one thing I ever I
think is the case if we ok d4 again was
winning a for Queen f4 I could have
killed me like a million times here but
one thing I'm pretty sure about is that
this isn't that great yeah and the
engine degrees so just this this doesn't
really help him because he trades up my
bad pieces and what's left is it's
rather active for me those bishops now
make sense and okay it's just a pawn the
position now is equal according to the
stock fish engine and I can believe that
we should be five immediately it was
maybe stronger yeah here it's it's it's
difficult for him satyr play check so
the engine evaluates the x equal at the
moment but this this is could be one of
the cases where the deeper calculation
reveals that white could actually be
better with all this activity it's hard
to same okay here after Luke c 1 i'm
clearly better and he i'm winning after
King e7
I should go Bishop Bishop takes e4 here
instead of Bishop d7 I didn't see we
should be six actually I hear you can
save themselves with 90 x g5 it's not
exactly easy to see you know this being
that shine but I can go Bishop g7 check
and this is still evaluated as better
for her for white by the computer what
what is this so if he goes here be sure
to d7 wow the Rope hasn't the rock is
strapped here somewhat and no this for
this trapping the rupiah that's Bassam
yes I make this stumbled into the funny
made yeah that was a pretty awful game I
played the opening quite badly and gone
into trouble and he could have won
multiple time so very lucky win at the
end ok guys thanks for watching